y hace dos años me paré en este mismo
escenario y hablé acerca de los
problemas que enfrentan los arrecifes de
coral para darles un pequeño resumen los
arrecifes de coral están desapareciendo
en todo el mundo de 1970 a la fecha se
han extinguido más de la mitad el
arrecife de coral es la columna
vertebral del mar más del 25 por ciento
de la vida marina está ligada
directamente al
es una fuente de alimentos medicamentos
y trabajo para muchísimas personas en
todo el mundo
pero lo más importante es que el mar
produce más del 60 por ciento del
oxígeno que respiramos y todo esto lo
estamos poniendo en juego
el arrecife mesoamericano es el segundo
recibo más grande del mundo y colinda
con más de 300 kilómetros con nuestro
país
según mis amigos de health services que
por cierto hacen un súper trabajo cada
año monitoreando y documentando la salud
de los arrecifes que actualmente se
encuentran así
un 1% está muy bien
un 13% está bien
un 23 28 está regular un 37% está en
malas condiciones y un 17% está en una
situación crítica una situación crítica
quiere decir que es muy difícil que la
recibe se pueda recuperar por sí mismo
ahora cómo está la parte con la que
colinda méxico un 1 por ciento está muy
bien solamente un 11 por ciento está
bien un 28 por ciento está regular un 38
por ciento está en malas condiciones y
un 22 por ciento está en una situación
crítica qué quiere decir que del 50 por
ciento que nos queda más de un 60 por
ciento está en una situación mala o
crítica
ahora que ha pasado en los últimos dos
años desde que decidí armar este
proyecto me encantaría venir a decirles
que todo marchaba de maravilla que el
proyecto va viento en popa y que he
tenido resultados extraordinarios pues
la verdad honestamente no ha sido así de
hecho el proyecto ya ni siquiera se
llama igual que cuando lo presenté hace
dos años
salir del último text con la ilusión de
que la gente ganaría la onda que el
problema que viene a plantear les
pegaría tan duro que saldrán a la calle
a contarle a sus amigos a sus vecinos a
la gente con la que trabajan que le
darían ser tantas veces al vídeo que
sería viral y una vez que el problema
estuviera bajo los reflectores mello
verían inversionistas activistas querían
inyectarle recursos chamba investigación
a mi proyecto pues la verdad
honestamente tampoco no sucedió como
muchas veces me fui al mar a desahogarme
ya contarle todos mis problemas y ahí
parado frente al azul turquesa del
caribe mexicano a sólo unos cuantos
metros del ecosistema que estoy
intentando proteger me di cuenta que
para resolver este problema tenía que
cambiar completamente la estrategia como
decía einstein no podemos resolver un
problema pensando de la misma manera que
cuando lo creamos
entonces de investigar diferentes
soluciones proyectos técnicas que están
utilizando en todo el mundo para
intentar resolver este problema me topé
con soluciones sumamente tradicionales
que se han venido haciendo durante
muchísimos años por ejemplo como hundir
barcos hundir aviones en sí hundir
cualquier objeto grande y hueco que
pueda albergar vida el problema con este
tipo de soluciones es que funcionan más
para grandes especies como peces
crustáceos anguilas etcétera pero para
la formación de coral no son las las
soluciones ideales
después me topé con otras soluciones un
poco más sofisticadas
por ejemplo en tailandia están hundiendo
estructuras metálicas y les están
aplicando un ligero voltaje a tan
pequeños corales a esta estructura y
gracias a la electricidad las partículas
de calcio que están flotando en el agua
se acercan hacia el coral entonces éste
puede construir de una manera más rápida
y más eficiente y la verdad han tenido
muy buenos resultados ahora este tipo de
soluciones tienen un gran problema y la
logística imagínense tener que construir
y luego hundir estructuras metálicas y
después descifrar cómo llevarle voltaje
o electricidad abajo del agua donde todo
se corroe con el tiempo y esto no es la
parte más difícil el coral tiene que ser
desarrollado en la superficie y son
organismos altamente sensibles por lo
que las condiciones tienen que estar
reguladas a la perfección
finalmente encontré la que yo pienso es
la mejor solución para poder hacer algo
por el arrecife mesoamericano rip ball
es una empresa que tiene fabricando
recife artificiales por más de 25 años
en florida
los materiales diseños procesos han ido
mejorando a lo largo de los años y lo
que más me gusta es que tienen cientos y
cientos de artículos con información
censos reportes que han ido reuniendo
durante todos estos años con excelentes
resultados después conocí a javier de
ayer javier es una de las pocas personas
con las que he coincidido que tiene esta
gran pasión por el mar él y su familia
tienen la licencia para fabricar rey
ball aqui en mexico
me invitaron a su fábrica que está
ubicada en santa clara yucatán y
utilizando moldes arena concreto fabrica
en unidades de 15 kilos hasta más de una
tonelada de peso después utilizando un
proceso especial regulan el ph del
concreto para que iguale al ph del agua
de mar
cada estructura se tiene que transportar
hasta la playa cerca de donde se hundir
y luego cada una
utilizando grúas se suben a una panga y
se llevan al lugar en donde se van a
hundir y después los buzos la vamos
bajando poco a poco hasta depositarlo en
el lecho marino es un todo un esfuerzo
pero créanme que vale la pena me fui a
esnorquelear aquí en en santa clara en
un lugar donde hace algunos años habían
hundido arrecifes artificiales y la
verdad lo que vi me impresionó
todo el lecho marino estaba cubierto de
macroalgas que básicamente es el enemigo
de los corales solamente en los
arrecifes que había hundido javier y su
familia hace algunos años se puedan
apreciar formaciones de coral tanto
corales duros como blandos y esto es
porque la superficie de la estructura la
porosidad que tiene la estructura y la
solidez que ofrece es exactamente las
condiciones que busca el coral para
adherirse y empezar a crecer también
pudimos apreciar varias especies de
arrecife cabe mencionar que aquí estamos
snorkel e ando en el golfo de méxico no
es el caribe mexicano que no son las
condiciones perfectas tiene buenas
condiciones pero el hecho de ver peces
de recife de ver formaciones de coral de
más de 30 centímetros de longitud
me dio una esperanza de que en verdad
podemos hacer algo por el arrecife de
hecho lo que hemos podido comentar es
que cada cinco años la estructura
duplica su masa que quiere decir que es
unimos una estructura de 800 kilos de
peso en 8 años vamos a haber producido
800 kilos de biomasa entre corales
esponjas algas etcétera
javier y su papá han hundido más de
20.000 arrecifes en todo méxico
normalmente lo hacían con proyectos
federales lamentablemente estos fondos
han ido disminuyendo con los años de
hecho los últimos años ya no hay fondos
para este tipo de proyectos
prácticamente han dejado de hacer este
trabajo tan importante para la
recuperación del ecosistema marino por
falta de fondos este es el principal
problema al que se enfrentan las
organizaciones no gubernamentales o
cualquier empresa que dependa
directamente de donaciones o de recursos
federales aún así estoy convencido que
ree fútbol es la solución con la que
vamos a salvar el arrecife mesoamericano
entonces decidí crear un proyecto
y lo hice basándome en dos premisas
fundamentales el primero es el dinero
casi todos los problemas ambientales
surgen gracias al dinero todos los
modelos de negocios o casi todos los
modelos de negocios actuales utilizan
conceptos que se han usado hace decenas
de años precio sobre costo de producción
oferta demanda en ninguno de estos
modelos se contempla la salud del
planeta o la felicidad de las personas o
de los empleados
el otro lado de la moneda son las ongs
estas si buscan resolver los problemas
ambientales o sociales pero en su modelo
de negocio no incluyen las ganancias una
ong puede llegar a gastar más del 40% de
lo que recaudó en volver a recaudar
recursos y si a esto le suma los gastos
administrativos gastos de operación
publicidad etcétera el dinero que le
llega en sí al problema es mínimo
del cielo me cayó un libro escrito por
joan ginard que es el fundador de la
marca patagonia en este nos cuenta cómo
a través de su empresa financia pequeñas
organizaciones que han resuelto grandes
problemas ambientales de hecho si se
enteraron de alguna de algún
acontecimiento importante en los últimos
años en eeuu por ejemplo como la
creación de nuevas reservas naturales o
que tuvieron la la construcción de una
represa probablemente fue a través de
una de las organizaciones que ivonne
swing art financia ok a través de su
empresa entonces decidí que la primera
premisa para mi proyecto es que tiene
que ser económicamente sustentable
la segunda es que el mensaje cualquier
esfuerzo que se haya de comunicación
tiene que tener una llamada a la acción
clara como puede esperar que las
personas hagan algo si yo en cuando yo
les doy un mensaje no les digo
exactamente qué es lo que espero de
ellos por ejemplo si yo hablo de una
idea o de un proyecto o de lo que sea
que quiera hacer pero no le digo
exactamente la gente que quiero que
hagan lo que más natural nos viene es
felicitar aplaudir y recomendar en el
caso de las redes sociales dar likes
el problema es que no se debe aplausos y
mucho menos de likes y tampoco podemos
esperar salvar un ecosistema solamente
con aplausos
entonces mi segunda premisa es que
existe una llamada a la acción clara y
así sobre estos dos pilares nació re
forest con este espero generar un flujo
constante de recursos que se van a van a
ser destinados a hundir el mayor número
de residuos artificiales como me sea
posible
creamos en nuestra primera fase una
plataforma en la cual las personas que
quieran ayudar van a poder
adquirir una de nuestras playeras de
algo no orgánico con fibras de bambú
y
por cada cuatro playeras que vendamos
vamos a poder fabricar y hundir un
arrecife para ponerlos un poco más en
contexto por cada cuatro playeras que
vendamos después de 15 años de haber
hundido este arrecife se van a haber
generado 3.2 toneladas de biomasa
gracias a su ayuda
mi meta personal es llegar a hundir cien
mil rifles en los próximos cinco años
con esto espero poder crear 320 mil
toneladas de biomasa en los próximos 15
años
también quiero ofrecer 270 mil metros
cuadrados de superficie de decisión para
los corales y no solamente para los
corales esta misma área le va a servir
para peces que sobre todo están en una
etapa temprana que tengan un resguardo
es cuando más lo necesitan
yo sé que el proyecto suena muy
ambicioso pero con esto solamente
logramos abarcar un 1% de la superficie
total del arrecife mesoamericano que
colinda con méxico
pero mi finalidad real es convertir este
1% en un movimiento que sume más
personas que cambien leyes pero sobre
todo que haga que las empresas se den
cuenta de la gran oportunidad económica
que existe en resolver problemas
ambientales y sociales y que nosotros
como consumidores podamos dictar el
rumbo hacia un futuro más justo y más
limpio gracias
[Aplausos]